suis étudiant je vais parler du
mouvement étudiant excusez moi mais
c'est pas très poli d'interrompre c'est
pas très poli de la télévision n'a pas
invité un étudiant pour parler du
problème étudiant je me transforme alors
jamais vous en cause je suis venu par
les problèmes étudiants dans une
démocratie un citoyen étudiant en droit
de parler de son problème j'en attends
qui était qui et des vitrines cassées
etc et des briques et de la bagarre qui
a un mort de malik oussékine et là tout
d'un coup ça intéresse parce qu'il ya du
sang qui a coulé beaucoup prié et
autrement l'éducation à la télévision
s'en tape oui quelques saisons mais là
c'est pas le sujet on va papa ne sera
jamais le sujet à la télévision vous
avez dû le pen vous avez lu mach à la
une en permanence le direction vous ne
parlez à rien pas de projet vous faites
simplement d'être d'aligner des chiffres
et des statistiques vous vous foutez de
la gueule du monde en permanence c'est
pas pour rien que j'ai menées non mais
là c'est du bon ce sera contre moi et
c'est vous qui n'ont verserez médias on
me censure en haut mais la vie est trop
précieuse là d'une précieuse que si on
la laisse s'exprimer en liberté